bonjour à toutes et tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle vidéo où nous allons
parler du film the batman une nouvelle
hype autour de la chauve souris se
dessine et franchement je suis très
content de partager ce sujet avec vous
et surtout il ya des choses
intéressantes à dire concernant ce film
et sa fin mais notamment aussi
concernant son potentiel futur la
tradition oblige je vais vous proposer
une petite vidéo analysé théorie autour
du film the batman je compte sur vous
pour me partager vos ressentis vos idées
et vos interprétations bien évidemment
néanmoins je préfère vous prévenir on va
sévèrement ce pôle et le film donc voilà
vous êtes prévenus et puis bah écoute et
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner à la chaîne
si ce n'est pas déjà fait écouter on
commence sans tarder tout d'abord il
faut que nous parlions de l'impact de la
fin du film car cela va nous permettre
de mieux appréhender le futur de ce
nouveau batman riddler où l'homme
mystère s'est fait arrêter par la police
et batman après sa succession d'énigmes
et des révélations concernant la
corruption et les nombreux mensonges
autour des personnalités influentes de
gotham l'acte final du plan de rigueur
sera l'inondation de gotham chose qui va
se dérouler en faisant exploser les
digues de gotham et les ponts de la
ville empêchant donc quiconque de sortir
et rien qu'avec cet acte final il y as
je trouve pas mal déjà de choses à dire
déjà le film respecte énormément
l'histoire des comics tout comme dans le
film riddler se met en scène à la
télévision pour poser ses énigmes face à
un batman qui est encore qu'à ses tous
débuts dans le film on le rappelle mais
cela fait seulement deux ans qu'il agit
en tant que batman et au final le
riddler va plonger gotham sous les eaux
grâce à cela ce dernier va pouvoir
prendre le contrôle total de la ville et
dans une thématique de nouveaux départs
relancera le calendrier en désignant son
nouveau règne comme l'an zéro évidemment
le film divergent concernant la fin de
ce périple puisque riddler se fera
arrêter par la police et batman
deviendra une sorte
icône d'espoir pour le peuple mais on
peut trouver quand même pas mal de
symbolique intéressante ce délire de
nouveau départ avec l'inondation de
gotham et je trouve plutôt importante
car le film the batman nous introduit
directement dans un gotham où tout est
déjà bien établie bruce wayne est déjà
batman depuis deux ans il est déjà
associé avec gordon les grands vilains
sont déjà installés carmine falcone et
le grand boss le pingouin dirige le club
et caetera et c'est avec l'inondation de
gotham toutes les cartes sont
redistribuées
une nouvelle ère s'offre à nous une ère
où gotham va devoir se reconstruire et
donc où plus rien n'est établi par
exemple l'un des points les plus
importants pour moi concernant ses
futurs changements et la mort de carmine
falcone ce vilain nous a été présenté
comme la personne qui a émergé de tous
les nombreux conflits de gotham au point
même qu'il est aujourd'hui celui qui
dirige tout gotham était tellement à sa
solde qu'on nous disait même qu'il était
le véritable maire de la ville
finalement aujourd'hui ce dernier a été
tué et cela promet un véritable chaos
pourquoi tout simplement car tout le
monde va vouloir prendre le pouvoir et
c'est là que nous pouvons creuser un
petit peu même si rien n'est confirmé
officiellement pour le moment il est
attendu que suite à the batman nous
ayons deux séries qui émerge une centre
est plutôt sur la police de gotham et
une autre centre et pourquoi pas sur le
pingouin la particularité de cette
nouvelle itération de batman c'est que
nous sommes sur une sorte d'introduction
le batman de robert pattinson n'en est
qu'à ses débuts il est en service depuis
seulement deux ans il fait face à sa
première grande menace via le riddler il
vient à peine de devenir un symbole
d'espoir pour le peuple de gotham ils
ignorent encore énormément sur les
origines de sa famille bref vous avez
compris l'idée sauf qu'évidemment cela
ne s'arrête pas seulement à bruce wayne
c'est le début de l'histoire et
l'introduction pour tous les autres
protagonistes de l'univers
ont notamment le pingouin le pingouin
est l'un des ennemis les plus populaires
de batman et on est loin d'avoir tout vu
concernant le personnage via ce premier
film si une série est dédié à cette
antagonistes c'est qu'il est important
et qu'il va revenir d'ailleurs étant
donné qu'il était comme une sorte de
bras droit pour carmine falcone il est
obligé que ce dernier tentera tout ce
qu'il faut pour prendre le pouvoir
désormais ensuite il faut bien
évidemment que nous parlions du joker et
par conséquent du fameux site rata la
d'appoint comme de ridder c'est quelque
chose que vous savez sûrement le citrate
al adha existe bel et bien à l'occasion
de la sortie du film d'ici nous
permettait via ce site de répondre à
plusieurs énigmes comme celle proposée
par le riddler afin de découvrir des
petits indices sur le long métrage
désormais depuis la sortie de the batman
rata la d'appoint comme a été mis à jour
pour nous proposer une barre de
progression et une image avec un message
à décrypter you think i'm finissent bat
fera absurde don't know they fall trou
evry ending is the new beginning
something is coming soit tu penses que
je suis fini batman mais peut-être que
tu ne connais pas toute la vérité chaque
fin est un nouveau départ quelque chose
arrive par le biais de la fin du film on
ne sait ce n'est pas la véritable fin de
riddler le joker qui semble saga lui lui
parle même de come-back la barre de
progression signifie à très fortes
chances l'annoncent d'une nouvelle
oeuvre ou d'une suite pour the batman
peut être pourquoi pas les fameuses
séries ou bien tout simplement un second
film il est apparemment supposer que the
batman serait une trilogie mais
peut-être que ce sera l'annnonce du
prochain bilan impossible de savoir au
moment où je vous parle petite
parenthèse pour être honnête quand j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser aussi de rata la
d'appoint comme je pensais qu on
progresserait d'un seul % par jour
puisque quand j'ai vu le film on était
le 5 mars et le film est officiellement
sorti le 2 mars et du coup le 5 mars on
était à 3% donc voilà trois jours après
1% par jour du coup je me disais à
stylet donc ça veut dire que bah du coup
dans 100 jours la barre sera complétée
on aura les informations le truc cachées
etc du coup ça emmené pour le 10 juin
j'avais si j'avais bien calculer mais au
final la barre progresse très vite il ya
même des chances que ce soit dès la
semaine prochaine où dès la fin de cette
semaine qu'on est un faux puisque au
moment où je vous parle on est déjà à
53% bon et pour revenir au joker qui est
d'ailleurs incarné par barry cogan car
ont divergé un petit peu eh bien je
pense personnellement qu'il ne faut pas
spécialement s'attendre à ce qu'il soit
le prochain vilain s'il ya une suite
comme je vous disais nous faisons face à
une introduction de l'univers batman est
encore à ses débuts les choses sérieuses
vont commencer pour lui mais du coup
c'est pareil du côté du joker dans le
batman nous faisons face un prêt joker
est d'ailleurs la mise en scène et je
trouve plutôt pertinente le joker n'est
pas introduit directement dans l'action
comme étant le véritable boss comme dans
la trilogie dark knight de nolan le
joker dans le batman est directement
introduit en prison seul tandis que
carmine falcone était le véritable boss
de la pègre nous sommes encore loin de
l'apogée du joker et il faudra du temps
et un bon développement afin de le faire
émerger face au batman de robert
pattinson qui a lui aussi besoin
d'évoluer on parle quand même du plus
grand ennemi de batman je souhaite de
tout coeur que d'ici fera les choses
bien personnellement s'il ya vraiment
une trilogie j'aimerais vraiment que le
joker soit un petit peu le boss ultime
de cette nouvelle itération en
apparaissant dans le troisième film
principalement et qu'ils agissent pour
le moment où second plan comme il semble
le faire dans le premier film enfin nous
pouvons terminer sur pourquoi pas
quelques antagonistes qui pourrait
apparaître à l'avenir bon le pingouin
c'est clair il en reviendra et pareil
pour le joker et et riddler est
d'ailleurs vu ce qu'ils nous ont proposé
dans le premier film et comment il s'est
déroulé il ya des chances qu'il fasse de
même pour les suivants c'est à dire nous
proposer plusieurs vilains dans le même
film par exemple la danse de batman on a
eu riddler on a eu le pingouin on a eu
carmine falcone et il ya même eu
salvatore maroni qui a été mentionné
c'est un procédé je trouve qui est
plutôt intelligent car cela renforce
clairement l'environnement de gotham
beaucoup de vilains sont des acteurs
majeurs de la ville donc c'est logique
qu'ils interagissent ensemble et où que
batman les relie bref c'était une
parenthèse pour être tout à fait honnête
je pense que d'ici avec cette nouvelle
épopée de batman souhaite proposer de
l'inédit cela peut sembler logique mais
c'est important de le souligner je
trouve par exemple je vous mentionne
souvent sony à ce sujet mais spider man
est un héros qui est plusieurs
itérations également et afin de proposer
toujours du neuf et bien sony nous a
présenté à chaque fois des vilains qui
n'apparaissait pas spécialement dans les
autres films eh bien je pense très
sincèrement que d'ici fera pareil avec
batman outre le joker qui est un cas
très spécial riddler est un vilain qui a
eu très peu d'apparitions voire pas du
tout dans les films batman alors oui il
est déjà apparu dans de très vieux films
mais cela n'a jamais été concluant le
pingouin en soit c'est pareil il est
déjà paru dans les vieux long métrage
mais on a eu peu de véritable apparition
concluante sur les productions plus
récentes
il est absent par exemple de la trilogie
dark knight alors c'est un vilain hyper
populaire de batman bref tout ça pour
dire que pour proposer de l'inédit je
suis certain mais ça reste un avis
personnel que d'ici souhaitera innover
sur les vilains qu'ils vont nous
proposer et pointent également important
c'est que vu les thématiques du film et
univers qu'il semble déployer pour le
batman de robert pattinson qui semble
très orienté détective est plutôt terre
à terre et bien je vous avoue que
j'aurai du mal à avoir des vilains de
batman avec des pouvoirs un peu
surnaturel comme par exemple mr freeze
cela casserait l'authenticité de
l'univers pour moi donc voilà vous avez
compris ce que je voulais dire néanmoins
il y a plein de vilains intéressant et
encore jamais vu sur grand écran qui
pourrait apparaître la cour des hiboux
en fait partie la cour des hiboux est en
gros une organisation secrète s'étalant
sur plusieurs générations elle est très
ancien et à la base composée des
personnages les plus riches et les plus
puissants de gotham agissant dans
l'ombre ce que j'aime bien avec cette
menace c'est que déjà on reste terre à
terre on est toujours dans le délire des
personnes influentes malveillantes qui
pourrissent gotham et surtout c'est une
organisation qui permettrait de révéler
le passé de la famille wayne qui dans le
film nous a été montré comme un point
central pour l'évolution de bruce wayne
qui manque de réponse on ne sait pas qui
a assassiné les parents de brousse dans
le film et nous savons que c'est un
élément qui reviendra pour le
développement de batman donc voilà
certains parlent également de
l'intégration de huf vu que son nom
apparaît sur la vidéo révélation du
riddler dans les comics c'est à
l'origine un ami d'enfance de bruce
wayne qui va mal tourner en jalousant la
chance que bruce a eu durant son enfance
en étant un enfant aimé de ses parents
et dont la richesse lui a toujours
permis de bien vivre malgré les
difficultés alors ce qui est intéressant
avec le ch c'est que son véritable nom
de famille est elliott si je ne dis pas
de bêtises c'est aussi le nom du
journaliste assassiné par carmine
falcone dans le film the batman vu que
tout le monde croit à cause du riddler
que thomas swain et celui qui a
commandité le meurtre du journaliste
et bien cela pourrait donner quelque
chose de cohérent que hull souhaite se
venger de la famille wayne et donc du
batman s'il est relié aux journalistes
pourquoi pas après tout comme il est dit
dans le film les péchés du père
retomberont sur le fils néanmoins ce qui
me titille un peu c'est que riddler
symbolisait déjà une sorte de hush dans
le film the batman ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'à la fin du film
leur nous mettait déjà sur la table les
problématiques du personnage de hush
hush c'est à dire un homme qui a une
véritable enfance difficile et dans la
précarité et qui pointe du doigt
l'injustice sur le fait que bruce wayne
qui osent d'ailleurs se revêtir d'une
cape de super héros était un enfant
choyé par tous car sa famille et est
influente et riche dans gotham donc
voilà pourquoi pas eux ce serait sympa
de rentrer dans un côté plus intime de
batman qui nous a été présenté comme un
pur solitaire mais j'ai peur que cela
fasse un peureux dit concernant les
problématiques
pour de vrai il est vraiment trop tôt
pour affirmer quoi que ce soit
énormément de vilains peuvent émerger et
à voir ce que nous révélera le site rata
la d'appoint comme en tout cas je suis
vraiment ravi de vous avoir parlé de
batman sur la chaîne je crois que c'est
une première si on ne compte pas
sneijder kuyt où on se concentrait plus
sur le groupe justice league mais voilà
c'est cool de parler aussi de l'univers
de dc de temps en temps on va s'arrêter
là je pense j'espère de tout coeur que
ma vidéo vous a plu si c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas évidemment a laissé un
petit pouce bleus et puis bah surtout à
me laisser un commentaire sur ce que
vous avez pensé du film j'ai vu que les
avis divergent et pas mal donc je suis
plutôt curieux d'avoir votre ressenti et
puis enfin n'hésitez pas évidemment à
vous abonner à la chaîne youtube pour ne
pas louper les prochaines vidéos en
attendant que le lay and rare soit avec
vous cet argot rock allez ciao tout le
monde
[Musique]